بالنسبه للمجتمع السعودي او الدوله
السعوديه الاولى مصاديرها محدوده هي اشخاص
عاصروا احداثها
والوثائق العثمانيه التي كانت
عباره عن مراسلات ما بين الولات
العثمانيين والسلطنه العثمانيه تصف واقع
هذه الدوله واحداثها ومجرياتها وما يحدث
فيها
تتردد بين الباحثين سعوديين وغير سعوديين
عرب وغير عرب هل هو على هذه الدرجه من
الاهميه فيما يخص تاريخ الجزيره العربيه
الان اي دراسه تريد ان تتناول تاريخ
الجزيره العربيه في الاربع عقود او الخمس
عقود في الخمس قرون الماضيه لا بد لك من
اللجوء او الذهاب الى الارشيف العثماني
كون هذه المنطقه كانت تحت الحكم الدوله
العثمانيه مباشره او بشكل هذه المنطقه
مسجل تسجيل دقيق من خلال وثائق ومراسلات
ومحفوظه في الارشيف العثماني نعم انا من
رواد الارشيف العثماني وقد اطلعت على
وثائق الدوله السعوديه الاولى كامله في
قلب الارشيف العثماني وما وخاصه ما يتعلق
بالحملات العثمانيه حمل الطوسون احمد باشا
وحمله ابراهيم باشا على الدرعيه هذا الملف
عدده انا حصلت على 118 وثيقه تم دراستها
وترجمتها وتحليلها وتفريغها
واستنباط
الهدف الاساسي من دراسات الثلاث وهو
النضال الوطني السعودي المشرف في مقاومه
الغزاه
كل الدراسات او مجمل الدراسات التي تحدثت
عن تاريخ الدوله السعوديه الاولى يعني
اغفل ثلاث نقاط النقطه الاولى التاريخ
الحقيقي لنشوء الدوله السعوديه الاولى وهو
1139 لحظه تولي محمد بن سعود لاماره
الدرعي وهو مرحله مبايعه الامام محمد بن
سعود بعد ان وحد شطري الدرعيه المليبي
واخصيبه وبدا ببناء الدرعيه وتحقيق
الاستقرار المجتمعي والامن الاجتماعي
والعدل والمساواه واسس واتخذ من الدرعيه
عاصمه لدوله جديده
الامر الامر الثاني هي القيم المجتمعيه
الحقيقيه التي نشات عليها الدوله السعوديه
الاولى